god bless us in Tennessee hey Douglas
what's up hey Uncle Dave and cousin
Chris how y'all doing we've been called
worse what's up well I apologize if
you've covered this topic recently but
I'm wondering is if in this well let's
call it the age of pandemic if you've
changed your investment strategy at all
or if you still recommend the four types
of mutual funds you've been recommending
all along Doug I can tell you this my
friend no change and in looking at this
we know that when you're investing it's
five years or longer and I can tell you
where people are feeling the heartache
and headache and those are people that
have grabbed on to single stocks and I'm
telling you they're swinging on pepto
and Maalox like it's going out of style
because of the ups and downs if someone
sneezes wrong or someone hiccups the
market is doing all these things so long
term five years or more and when you
track that five year sector the market
always comes back look back at y2k 9/11
the SARS epidemic of o2 and o3 and even
the Great Recession in o-72 oh nine the
market does come back we just have to be
patient yeah and the exact same
categories come back the four types
aggressive growth or your small
companies and they're the Wilder ride
growth which is the medium forage that
just right porridge we call it a
Goldilocks
the growth and income which is the
conservative big companies and then
overseas or international stocks and
Douglas in my mind I personally am still
invested across those four and I can't
think of a logical reason not to be
because I don't think any one of those
sectors or anyway those areas of the
economy is doomed on a 10-year basis
based on a really bad April with a
pandemic what do you think I agree I was
just curious if your take had changed
any because honestly I trust your
financial advice better than my own well
I appreciate that but the thing is this
I'm not unwilling to change we're not
unwilling to change if we see the
landscape shift
as a matter of fact like two years ago I
did an in-depth study on the
international funds because for like 15
years they've been the dog of the for
they suck compared to the other three
and I thought you know maybe I need to
change this mix and dump the
International and we found some really
good statistical evidence that that
would be a bad idea because they run
inverse with the other funds typically
depending on the type of economic strain
that you run into and so they're way
overdue for an upward spike which is
kind of like washing my car as soon as I
do it rains right so as soon as I dump
those things out of one of my four then
those things would go through the roof
and I'd look like a doofus getting out
just at the wrong time so um you know we
but we did consider changing though
because you know we had lots of we got
some of our smart mister pros together
and we did in depth we run up a whole
bunch of hypotheticals on the market and
and historical data data and looked at
all of it so we're not unwilling to
change but the good news is is that
something is boring and predictable as
the type of advice that we have here
that just works all the time it's just
like you know you don't have to change
it much it's not like I'm suddenly gonna
tell people to start using their credit
card or suddenly gonna tell people to do
this so I appreciate the question but
and sometimes we get accused I hear I
read the stuff sometimes on social media
Dave Ramsey doesn't know what he's
talking about with investing he's only
got several hundred million dollars so I
don't know how he got that he must be an
idiot but um you know so yeah just don't
make any sense yeah and so but you know
so I you know we're unsophisticated and
so we're one size fits all well one size
of gravity fits all mmm you jump off a
building one size fits all there's a big
boys down and a little boy it sure does
did you uh what about cryptocurrency
Dave you got some of that yeah no don't
having gold got some gold cuff links and
you got you got a car lease Oh Dave you
know no no paid cash for it just making
sure yeah just making sure I want to
fire you today I mean you go get people
out there that are Douglas that are
overthinking this thing and I'm telling
you that's what's scaring you Doug it's
scared to crap out of people
you know and market douve down and it
was something so such a weird vibe in
the air yeah you could smell it yeah and
it makes people rethink things so I
appreciate you getting the clarify but
it's not because we're dinosaurs and
we're unwilling to change it because we
look at the future and we say logically
over a 10-year period of time a 20 or 30
year period of time what's wrong with
this nothing so we're not changing okay
this is the Dave Ramsey show